you know if I didn't have to worry about
copyright strikes I'd probably be
singing something from Newsies right
about now
[Music]
you know the real fun thing about making
that reference is thanks to the fact
that school my kid goes to the musical
that they did in the spring was Newsies
it's now so much easier for me to
explain to her what the heck is going on
in Hollywood right now because she's got
a point of reference anyways
striking it continues with the writers
and now the actors are striking so uh By
the time this video comes out they'll
have been on uh the picket lines for
about a week I
am kind of shooting this a bit in
advance I have a lot
on this coming week but I'm also kind of
assuming it's not going to be resolved
a course of a week if it does I will
look quite foolish but then again if it
does I probably will have to scrap this
video and do something altogether so
you'll never know anyways regardless
sag after that is the union for uh film
and television as well as radio
personalities and voice actors they are
now on strike now if you are wanting
some background on the writer strike
which is now at this point the longest
running strike definitely of the writers
you can I think of any Union in
Hollywood at this point
um you can see the earlier video I did
pretty much everything I said there
still stands it's just been dragging on
continuously the actors strike is by its
nature
far more disruptive than the writer
strike was and the writer strike was
already pretty disruptive but I kind of
talked about in that video how the
actual trickle-down effects of a writer
strike won't become evident until months
maybe even a year or so later when all
the projects that were rushed into
development on unfinished scripts
um before the start of the strike start
coming out you see how bad they actually
are you know that's how we ended up with
things like X-Men Origins Wolverine
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen etc
etc
the impact of an actor strike way more
immediate it how immediate well uh the
cast of Oppenheimer literally walked out
during the premiere because when actors
strike it's not just the acting that
they don't do they don't do the
promotional stuff either another quite
amusing uh Premiere related thing that
happened was Disney still went ahead
with their premiere for The Haunted
Mansion even though no actors were going
to show up and so they just sent
character performers like from their
Parks like Mickey and Minnie Mouse and
Cruella and Maleficent
okay that's a choice oh we'll be coming
back to Disney in particular Uh current
CEO Bob Iger in a little bit as far as
major projects that have shut down it's
a long list and I'm not going to go
through all of it but examples Deadpool
3 that had to shut down shooting second
season of sandban on Netflix that had to
shut down shooting as well as
innumerable others how I'll just had to
close down stop work regardless of where
they were in the production now one of
the things that's kind of interesting
about this again compared to the writer
strike is that there really wasn't a lot
that could be done by the studios on
this now as I mentioned already in the
other video and kind of alluded to here
with the writer strike when that was
looming they were perfectly capable of
launching into production stuff with
unpolished scripts happening scripts
scripts that were given a shorter time
frame to be finished than would have
otherwise happened so that they could go
into production
um before the strike started or you even
after the strike started just with the
knowledge that the script couldn't be
revised anymore the thing is though
while you can make a writer or writing
team even work faster
budget less time
time you can't really do that with
actors you can't make them act faster
especially because the speed of
production is not solely dependent on
them the amount of time a film or
television show takes to shoot is
completely logistically based the amount
of time that writers need like there are
logistical concerns how long will it
take to physically write it out but
aside from that if you want to Crunch
writers really badly in terms of how
much time you're allowing for them you
can there isn't a ton of uh condensing
you can do on a film shoot like there
are some things you can do there you can
try and get night shoots get more stuff
shot in a day but first of all how much
you're able to do that is already kind
of hampered by not only actors unions
but the unions of the various other
professions who work on a set and just
logistically there's only so much you
can shoot in a day
so while when the writer strike was
looming they could Rush the writing
process to get stuff into production
they couldn't Rush stuff that was in the
process of being shot through the
shooting uh in order to get it done
before the actor strike that's simply
not feasible
so all this stuff just gets closed down
and we're really going to see the impact
of this because uh assuming that it goes
forward which it should but San Diego
Comic-Con is going to be pretty Bare
Bones this year because it is happening
the same weekend this video goes up
now a bunch of
bunch of weren't planning on attending
at all basically assuming that the
strike was likely to happen
enough that was planned had to be
completely canceled there was gonna be
stuff related to uh good omen season two
that has been paired down to just an
advanced screening of I think the first
one or two episodes
um Marvel nor DC are going to be in Hall
age this year normally one of them
Stakes that out as a major thing that's
not happening all this stuff has to be
paired down because who do audiences get
most excited about
the actors they're the ones who get sent
to these things to promote this stuff
and they're not going to do that now now
it's probably worth going over what the
sticking points appear to be uh in
regards to the actual striking and a lot
of it is actually very similar it runs
very parallel to why the writers are
striking uh there are two major areas
the first is compensation the second is
AI dealing with compensation the
specifics and the nuances and the nuts
and bolts of it are a bit different from
the writers but ultimately they come
down to the same core Factor the nature
of production of both film and
television as well as how these things
are compensated especially in the age of
streaming have changed in a way that the
old payment structures that used to
enable actors to make a livable wage are
no longer working they're not making
what they need to make now I know it's
very easy when we think of actors to
think of the big name over title at
Tom Cruise The Rock
no Kidman
's per project the thing is though
the union doesn't just represent them
about a quarter of working actors those
being people who it is their primary if
not exclusive form of income only make
about thirty thousand dollars a year and
if that sounds like a livable wage to
you keep in mind
the vast majority of actors live either
in Los Angeles or New York City
thirty thousand dollars a year
is not a livable wage in either of those
cities
so the union has a lot of people to look
out for not just the big names that you
tend to think of when you think of
actors and that also includes
background actors and we'll get into
that a little bit when we talk a little
bit more about the AI and like let's be
clear residuals for actors have always
been subject to some really screwy
economics uh someone who recently spoke
out about that was John Cusack he
highlighted his film say anything you
know the one the more he holds the
Boombox up everybody knows that one it
wasn't a major hit at the time that it
was released but it's become pretty
iconic and a bit of a cult hit since
then uh he did have in his contract that
he was supposed to get some royalties
off that he never has because officially
on paper that film over its lifetime
lost 44 million dollars
that's pretty impressive considering the
movie only had a budget of 13 million
and it didn't have a major marketing
push and has been re-released in
multiple home video formats yet somehow
it managed to lose a million dollars a
year every year since it came out more
than that
that's pretty impressive
that's Hollywood accounting
but as far as compensation goes the way
things have changed in the era of
streaming with shorter Seasons a lot
more things now being done uh fewer
episodes per season and what actually
results in terms of the payment up front
as well as the residuals actors just
aren't making what they used to just
flat out most of them are not and the
union feels very strongly that they are
not making a appropriate percentage of
the revenue being brought in by this
incredibly successful industry so
compensation is what these sorts of
negotiations are honestly usually about
whether it breaks down or not whenever
these contracts need to be renegotiated
the sticking point is pretty much always
going to be how compensation works and
by and large part of the job of the
unions is to figure out what ways they
are currently being shortchanged and
possibly exploited but also to try and
look ahead and get ahead of possible
ways they might be exploited in the
future and that's where we get
into to actors is a point of concern for
the same reasons it was with writers it
is not
feasible for generative AI which is
already kind of dicey in terms of
legality particularly when it comes to
copyright and likeness rights because
it's not truly generative it is
reiterative it has to have reference
material in order to generate anything
but I'm not going to break down uh the
very nature of AI but
even setting aside the inherent legal
issues with AI and whether or not it is
already running a foul of existing
copyright laws or copyright laws that
may catch up with it with where it's
currently going even setting all that
aside it can't currently just create a
performance of an actor just like you
can't currently create a workable
shooting script
but what it could feasibly do in the
future is
create performances for background
background for second unit shooting for
things other than the here's our lead
actor the name over the title type actor
we're getting a close-up sure you can't
use AI to do that but maybe you could
use it to fill in some gaps do some
pickup shooting some long shots so that
they're not on set as many days you
don't have to pay them as much
uh one particular story that came out uh
this was cited by Duncan Crabtree
Ireland who is the chief the chief
negotiator for sagaptra uh he said that
what the studios had proposed in regards
specifically to background actors was
that they be paid uh any given
background actor be paid for one day's
work get scanned and then that would
allow the studio to use that scan and AI
to create a background performance of
them without compensation and in
perpetuity now the amptp which is
representing the major Studios and
producers and Executives disputes that
characterization and they claim that
what the proposal actually was that
background actors yes would only be paid
for one day they would be scanned but
then that scan data would only be used
to create background performances for
that movie and their scan data could not
be used in other projects without
compensation negotiations
Etc now if we assume that what the
studios and produce users are saying is
the more accurate version of what they
were proposing that's still not good
because you're cutting the number of
days that they're going to get to work
uh a shoot goes particularly in large
crowd scenes some of the bigger more
elaborate stuff that has a lot of
background extras you're looking to cut
them out of multiple days of work weeks
of work and compensate them only for a
single day even if it's true that you
can't use that data again in another
project without compensating them for it
again that's still a massive insane pay
cut that you are looking to be able to
do to them and also can we be honest
even if their original proposal was I
don't know we'd only use it more in the
same movie not in other stuff okay that
seems really easy to abuse though
because do you think people are going to
be able to notice in every single movie
the random background figure out of
focus one of hundreds is their face that
is being used without conversation
do you think they'd be able to prove it
and that's not even getting into the
idea that with that scan data they could
simply Tinker with it in AI a little bit
so it doesn't look completely like the
original person and then how heck is
that person ever going to prove that
their scan data was used
so even if the guy from zagastra
exaggerated I don't think he's being
unfair in what could potentially happen
even if that would technically be uh an
abuse of the proposed contract
stipulations but like let's be honest if
it's that easy do some of them are gonna
do it maybe not all of them but some of
them will
just don't give them the opportunity
I'm with sag like let's be very clear I
was sag across the board on this just
like I was with the wga when they first
started striking I'm signing with them
against these Studios and AI is a
concern across the board even the
Director's Guild which is not striking
and does in fact have a tentative
agreement with uh the studios and the
executives they have also put forward
concerns about AI specifically in the
contract that they have it says duties
performed by DGA members must be
assigned to a person and generative
artificial intelligence does not
constitute a person now of course the
studios do have their own justifications
for why they think this is unreasonable
but unfortunately some of them have also
said some stuff that really does very
clearly paint them as the bad guys in
all this
because as I said some people might
think oh actors are striking they think
of big name actors in The Hollywood
Hills with millions of dollars but
as I said that that's not all that is
affected by this and the studios are not
doing much to make themselves look good
right now first there was an article
that came out in deadline where a number
of Executives uh all of whom spoke
anonymously had a number of things to
say however I'm going to narrow it down
to uh this Choice quote the end game is
to allow things to drag on until union
members start losing their apartments
and losing their houses
this sentiment was reiterated by similar
sources with one calling it quote a
cruel but necessary evil
they're flat out admitting that holding
out the strike dragging it out and
refusing to give in until people start
losing their homes is evil but they will
do it
yeah that's generally not something that
the good guys do is it and uh nobody's
taking this line down the actors
especially Ron Perlman
did not mince words at all when
responding to that bit
you wish that I'm people you wish the
family starve while you're making 27
million dollars a year for creating
nothing
be careful mother be really careful now
the thing is quotes like that in
deadline either shows that these people
in the executive level are trying to run
interference like that they're hoping
that this is posturing they'll make it
look like they're going to be willing to
wait things out until people start
losing their homes in the hope that it
will bring the um at the time it was
mostly the writers but in the hope they
will bring both unions back to the
negotiation table or
they're very very stupid and don't
understand the position that they're in
because
um right now
the studios are actually pretty
vulnerable
there have been a number of very high
profile underperforming films this would
include the likes of Elemental The Flash
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
and then there's all the cuts that have
been having to stream these Services
they claim because of the expense of
keeping all the stuff on their servers
so right now that makes these Studios
pretty vulnerable now they may try and
play that to their advantage and try and
plead poverty like look we're losing
money at the box office we're having to
make these cuts to streaming services
clearly we don't have the money to give
you what it is you want
and there are some who have basically
expressed as much in particular there's
Bob Iger over Disney told you we'd come
back to him in regards to the strikes he
said it's very disturbing to me there's
a level of expectation that they have
that is just not realistic and they're
adding to the set of challenges that the
business is already facing that is quite
frankly very disruptive yeah Bob
it's disruptive
it's a strike
it's supposed to be disruptive
if it didn't disrupt things it'd be a
pretty bad strike
wouldn't it And in regards to Bob Iger
in particular or anybody but we're gonna
single him out because he's the one who
chose to open up his mouth and put his
name on some statements
it's uh pretty infuriating given the
compensation that we know he gets or
actually I'm gonna let Sean Gunn take
this one in 1980
um CEOs like him made 30 times what the
worker with the lowest worker was making
now Bob Iger makes 400 times with his
lowest worker is and I think that's a
shame Bob and maybe you should take a
look in the mirror and one ask yourself
why is that and not only why is that is
it okay is it morally okay yeah
like seriously in an ethical Society
Cuts would start at the top because
before making that stupid callous and
Bob Iger did actually point to some
problems that were self-inflicted by the
studios he talked about how interest in
the Marvel properties and the Star Wars
properties had dwindled and he partly
singled out that they had oversaturated
the market too much stuff people were
getting fatigued and he's not wrong
but he wants to take that loss
out on actors and writers and everybody
who isn't an executive when it's the
executives who are making those calls
that made things bottom out and made it
so you aren't making as much money as
you think you should I would say the
ones who should be getting their
salaries cut are the ones making the
decisions Bob
or you know what I'm gonna hand over the
mic one more time though this time to uh
somebody who you might not be as
familiar with
um Mr Nutter butter
it should Bob
thank you love that guy
and yeah people aren't taking lightly uh
Bob iger's comments either Fran Drescher
who is the current uh president of
sagafra uh slammed him harshly and
rightfully so
because as I said
he's not posturing as much he is kind of
saying like look we're already going
through tough times you're gonna do this
now yeah Bob we're gonna do this now but
you have the others uh that spoke to
deadline in what honestly feels like a
borderline propaganda piece to try and
make them look stronger than they are
but even if it's not then it was just
them being very very stupid because
they are not in a particularly powerful
position in these negotiations
because the thing is
this point
the true customer of these Studios
it's not you
it's not me
it's not viewers
they don't really care what we think
it's the shareholders
everything they do
is driven by what will influence the
shareholders that's not to say pleasing
customers doesn't matter because that's
about Optics and making it look like the
customers don't care or are being driven
away will drive down the stock will
anger the investors
and that's why I say these studios are
not in a particularly strong negotiating
position
because
at this point
these companies pin so much on quarterly
earnings
and everything has stopped
all the work has stopped
new stuff that was not already to the
point of being in post-production you
know editing and special effects Etc if
it wasn't already at that point it
stopped everything will be impacted by
this everything will be pushed back and
yes you can fill your television
schedule with uh you know stuff that is
non-union reality shows being the big
one
but that's not the prestige stuff that's
not the stuff that drives engagement
that's not the stuff that drives new
people coming to you that's not the
stuff that excites investors investors
get excited by big new Prestige projects
with all that stuff stopped
the Stock's going to start taking a hit
and it's not going to take long to do it
the studios are going to do what they
can to try and fill in the Gap like we
already know that Ms Marvel is going to
be repackaged for network television
which I believe it'll be the first time
a Disney plus uh original that was
intended only for the service gets moved
to another platform it's going to
premiere on ABC next month but that's a
limited resource there isn't a lot that
they can do and that only solves the
issue of no new stuff on the network
that doesn't solve the issue of new
stuff not coming out for the streaming
platforms it's not even a stop Gap but
it is the kind of thing that they're
stuck doing if they don't want to just
fill their entire schedules with reality
shows the thing is people like Bob Iger
are criminally
overpaid for what it is they do
I'm sorry it should be credible it
should not be legal to make as much more
money than anyone employed by him as Bob
Iger or any of these CEOs do
it is callous it is a moral and it
should be Criminal
it is at the very least obscene
like
naked bodies aren't obscene
the salaries of these people that is
obscene
but the thing is
as obscene as his salary Maybe
maybe know where the real money is
it's in bonuses
and whatever stock he also gets to have
as the head of the company
the stock starts losing value
that's a hit and the bonuses are usually
contingent on the stock price majorly if
not exclusively
so even though he already makes way too
much money somebody like Bob Iger is
suddenly going to be making a bit less
than he thought he was going to
he'll have a reason to come back
they all will
because the only justification they have
for the position of power that they hold
is that they keep the money flowing
because they don't create art
they don't create the products the
entertainment the performances the
scripts they don't create anything
that we enjoy
their only claim to power is that they
keep the money coming
but
when that gets disrupted
what is it you do exactly
why are you here
why should you be kept in that position
why should you not be replaced
how many Yachts are you gonna have to
sell
oh no
what a burden
yeah I have no sympathy for these people
at all
and while I can empathize with people
who are outside of these specific
striking unions who are also seeing
their works stop as the sets get shut
down I can and do have some sympathy for
them
they ultimately benefit from this as
well in the long run
because if everybody's getting screwed
then everybody's getting screwed
people taking a position
people standing up and saying hey you
can't treat us like this that's
snowballs
unions have a positive impact
on the working conditions and
compensation of workers even those who
are not in those unions if those unions
are still in place in those workspaces
so while I have sympathy for anyone who
is looking at an immediate financial
crunch
from this and I'm not calloused to that
I still think this is in the best
interest of everybody who as far as I'm
concerned matters because Studio heads
don't matter
they don't
they absolutely do not
so if you're like me and you want to
support the actors and the writers what
can you do well here's the first thing
you shouldn't do
don't start boycotting Studios or
streaming services or Networks
they are not asking you to do that and
it doesn't help and I know this can be a
weird point because like when I did
videos like say the one I did on the
abuse of the animators in the making of
across the spider verse I mentioned that
I may not be comfortable watching Beyond
the spider verse when it comes out some
people took that as a call to boycott it
wasn't it was me talking about my own
personal Comfort level in watching it
and why I might not be comfortable when
that comes out if it is not in some way
delayed and we don't know if the working
conditions ever got any better but that
wasn't actually called to boycott I
don't think I've ever done a formal call
to boycott what I have done is explained
why I think supporting this or that
might have negative effects or why I
personally do not intend to support or
see or pay for this or that but here let
me be very explicitly boycotting is not
helpful
what is helpful is following the actors
who are vocal the organizations
themselves on whatever form of social
media you can using the hashtags
vocalizing your support I know that the
online sense of things like it feels
like it doesn't matter like online
activism social media activism who cares
well the thing is in an industry like
the film industry that is all about
perception and the uh sense of how
willing the public is to take in what it
is you're giving them
like because entertainment isn't a
necessity trying to boycott something
that is more of a necessity that's
really really difficult especially in a
social media sense so you know trying to
boycott I don't know petroleum products
good luck
and especially doing it like over social
media but the thing is
again because of the eyes of the
investors and the sense of do people
still like what it is you're doing are
we still going to make money off this
should I keep investing into your studio
the public perception of the public
supporting the actors and the writers
matters it does help them and if you
want to help more directly there's the
entertainment Community Fund now this is
a fund that is being used to counter
exactly what those jackasses who spoke
to deadline are trying to do which is to
starve people out this is a fund that is
used to help ensure that writers actors
or anyone else impacted by this that is
not at the executive level
has access to funds to help ensure that
they don't lose their housing that they
don't go hungry so if you want to help
most directly that is the way to do it
the reason boycotting doesn't help
especially in a case like this is
because while negotiations are currently
ongoing
these entities do still have to exist at
the end of the negotiation if an actual
if effective boycott of something like
Netflix was done and it had to like
scale down everything that doesn't
ultimately help the writers or the
actors because now there's simply less
work there and boycotts are complicated
anyway but it's a little bit more
straightforward when it comes to
Industry related stuff like this
specifically when it comes to
negotiations and the unions if you want
to support the unions don't boycott
share the hashtags share your own
outrage and if you are able
a lot of us aren't but if you are able
to donate to the entertainment Community
Fund that will help
and I wish them the best
I want them to break these Studios
I really really do
and I think they can
because like I said the studios are not
in a particularly strong negotiating
position
they just aren't
they need to be able to tell their
investors okay
we didn't have the best year this year
but here's what we've got coming up and
it's all on schedule and it's all going
ahead as planned and they can't do that
right now even the ones who have had
better years
they can still be going well look we did
have a good year but they still have to
be able to tell their investors and
here's why next year's got to be even
better it's hard to sell that idea when
you can't make anything
so
I think they have the negotiating power
in this situation
to get what they're after and I hope
they do
so that's the actors strike
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills it's how you can support
me and ensure that I am able to stay in
my home and
and eat and feed my kid and so on and so
forth
even if you can't help me out that way
there's links in the description for
other things that I do works that I have
ways you can support me but ultimately
what I want you to remember
especially
if you're on the picket line
you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks my patreon supporters to
make this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Linda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 bernabe likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my the bat I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
foreign